that's great it's white night at the
Apollo not everybody I'm sure know
here's that way everybody there are some
people here who had been out in the Sun
for a little bit
I enjoyed the Alvin Ailey the dancing no
you liked the dancing thing yeah dancing
is really inspiring to watch when
somebody you know it's a terrible life
choices the dumbest it's the worst
career choice you're saying dancing is a
terrible career choice you like watching
it but you think it's a terrible career
forest available career choice it's you
massive amount of dedication followed by
giving up that's what FBA life because
you know we're talking there's like
three dance jobs on the planet Earth and
there's no second tier like any other
even a musician even being a musician
and on there what are you doing don't be
a musician that's a stupid thing to do
for a little butt but if it doesn't work
out the way you want it you can look at
these you've got these guys
no no no just to be clear what I'm
saying well these guys I'm saying is
that nobody cares who they are is
individual right there no wait wait wait
wait let me finish inside you gotta let
me they're working musicians none of
this is not their dream none of them
none of them they each wanted to be
separate rock stars there's just a clump
nothing that makes a noise they're
supporting their families this is they
they are supporting their families and
they're paying their rent by just being
nothing nobody that anyone cares making
a noise that a computer can make is that
a musician that's a viable look at this
the guys are great example yeah that's a
good idea
idea you're saying dancing it's not
likes right if you did if you're a
dancer and you're the greatest dancer
ever nobody gives a [ __ ] first of all I
mean that because everybody dances and
then how many millionaire dancers are
there I don't you can dance if for like
two seconds at your peak you got to give
up you know I mean stripping you can
strip but but you can you don't need to
go to Alvin Ailey to learn to do that
yeah that's a good career choice right
being a stripper so as far as
financially financially yes thing look
and that's why they're wonderful people
because they're doing something very
stupid that we can watch I mean it's
stupid for their lives
wonderful for ours no listen Louie are
you saying
[Laughter]
you